so what happened to your startup well I
took a break because that's some other
priorities going on yeah I want to work
on personal development you know
building relationship networking and
also just overall learning more and
while I was doing that I had to look
over to my old hard drives because I
want to find some important documents
and some important notes and I found
something pretty interesting and when I
clicked into it you know I just opened
up the wallet and oh and there it is and
then it hit me I remembered you know I
used to mine bitcoins it was probably
like five five or six years ago
I remember trying to get enough so that
I could buy a pizza slice but I just
couldn't get enough I mean I think you
had
I think you need like ten thousand big
ones to get a slice of pizza but yeah I
only had like a hundred something but
and then I checked the price and I was
like oh yeah and I said to myself my god
what am i and do of all that money it's
crazy
all the things I can buy but then I
remembered I live in Silicon Valley all
I can afford a new house yeah I guess
I'm a homeowner now but I mean I ran out
of money so I have to start making money
again but yes so that's why I'm back the
pitch one of the most important aspect
of your startup no matter how great your
ideas if you can't convey it and you
don't have any capital then your startup
is useless and if you can't inspire
people and you don't have a team already
working for you then your startup is he
useless but wait what if I can make a
product that doesn't require much
capital and I don't need a team I could
do it by myself well I mean if you can't
convey your idea to customers then
you're not gonna have any customers and
if you don't have any customers then
your startup
useless every interaction relating to
your star you will somehow require to
pitch it now that is why it is essential
to perfect your pitch easier said than
done
here are the seven questions that you
should answer as clearly as possible
with these in mind you'll be able to do
ten-second pitches to a five-minute
presentation with demo number one what
do you do be as clear as possible no
fluff no potion to test it the email
tests write two sentences describing
your startup in an email send it to a
competent friend and ask him to re
explain to you with his own words if
they can do that then you are golden
number two how big is the market
investors care about ROI if there's no
market for a product then their
investment isn't worth it don't make
your target market too wide or too
narrow make it correct you're only
wasting people's time if you're making
up numbers number three what's your
progress they want to make sure you guys
are actually doing something what is
possible in a given time frame what can
you do number four what's your unique
insight or in some sense what's your
competitive advantage how are you
different than the start of next door
what makes you more likely to succeed in
your market number five
what's your business model how are you
gonna make money or Yuda grow fast think
about money later kind of company or
we'd be making money right away it's
always better to have a plan of attack
when it comes to monetization number six
who's on your team what are your
credentials whose technical who's not
who's doing what is everyone useful are
you as lean as possible number seven
what do you want
this can be capital convincing someone
to work for you or simply to tell your
mom that you're actually doing something
and that you're not wasting her life
savings on your pet projects and that
this time it's gonna blow up for sure
once you have these answers now compress
it into 30 seconds here's my my startup
is called not fine comm platform to
create and share six point one second
videos we have a market size of at least
200 million given the fact that a
similar product has just left this
market i made no progress i understand
the market both consumer and producer
have been working in the publishing
industry for over five months which
makes me an expert in social media and
media publishing you can monetize
through advertisement branded content
and recent posts i am currently the only
one on my team and i want you to join my
starter
[Music]
[Applause]
what's your background
oh I just worked on a couple of startups
mostly just like fitness related
startups so how do you know Jamba uh
he's my best friend's ex what was the
break-up like pretty bad I mean I'm sure
Joe must still cries over it we don't
now you're all here because you're the
best engineers ago
now I need something from you yet and
today I'm gonna talk about my starter
here's my presentation velocity
compassion spirituality what do all
these things have in common I present to
you not vine calm a platform to share
6.1 second long looping videos oh you
know I love him man you know vine was
vine was awesome but not like it's gonna
be better it's gonna be way better
excited oh I don't know pretty dumb to
be honest
dude the start of I'd use it utterly
ridiculous I created for starters by the
time I was 18 I can build that back-end
infrastructure during an episode of
Battlestar Galactica well I'm just a
public delivery guy but you know when I
saw those slides I thought it was pretty
cool
Jonah seems like a pretty cool CEO how
did dream it's gonna be like really
really successful and then after that I
had another dream about Taco Bell and
Wendy's creating like a burrito burger
so all in all I'm really excited about
it we do work for a start-up oh dude no
and what else it's also a mobile oh I
think it's great I love vine and always
been with checking those videos and
being on it yeah I think it's awesome
then they're bringing it back
you do realize it's not vine right we
went the opportunities research shows
that door was a similar product that
reached 200 million active users on
December 2015 but that product is no
longer in the market and left a need
unsatisfied that is where we come in
the thing is a complete and utter scam
it's not only Bitcoin which is
legitimate it's like dumbass like coin
or etherium I would never pay it
launched roadmap so far oh yeah he likes
he's my my follower he's followed me on
Instagram Twitter snapchat and then one
day you just like messaged me and yeah
we started talking yeah I think his
handle is at Joma oppa that's Jay oh ma
oh and our main competitive advantage me
what do you think about Jenna as a CEO
oh yeah he's a really great friend Jamal
is a really bad boyfriend there's this
one time when he forgot Christina's
birthday because he was so immersed in
watching buying videos market research
let me explain this for you commonplace
people if this was Star Trek The Next
Generation I would be Commander data
because I'm a genius
he would be lieutenant ward because he's
just running around and making stupid
decisions all the time I bet Joma had to
study off Jack Overflow to make it
through a [ __ ] Microsoft interview I
would never work for the start-up in a
million years not even a million
light-years and that's not even a time
it's a distance now was her business
model now we have a lot of sources of
revenue we got advertisement 70% oh yeah
sure man I'm just chilling right now but
I'll definitely work for them do you
have a job right now you know I'm in
between jobs
you know just in that in between my mom
always says I'm an entrepreneur
what's your criminal record
next steps so what we need to do next we
need to create the iOS app we need to
make the back-end a lot stronger and we
need to innovate don't was a pretty good
guy he gets Bubba was a hundred percent
sweetness just like Atari John one
drinks his boba with 100 percent
sweetness to match all the marketing
platforms any questions yes people are
looking for yeah so I'm looking for like
flexible engineers you know engineers
who are pretty much full stack back and
front end if you're not afraid of
touching all these pieces of code then
yeah you're definitely good for jobs you
can do that would you do with $420 69 6
yeah that's a good question
I mean I'll definitely invest in not
Viacom I mean we need as much capital as
we can so yeah definitely invest it any
more questions
okay turn to camera hey do yourself
interrupting all right any more
questions what's your tech stack well um
well you know like the mean stack yeah I
mean we could do that
the nice stack - I mean like it is it's
pretty flexible right now yeah so I mean
nice stack means that you know it's all
good it depends on what you want you
know do you even code of course come on
I mean have a CS agree first of all the
name not fine
it's not gonna work and I don't know I
just wasn't listening honestly do you
think they make your pitch of course not
do I mean I'm not stupid I know what
they're saying but that's the thing not
fine it's just a marketing scheme
or something bigger happy new years
everybody was now if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to click the
subscribe button and also turn on post
notifications because that will tell you
when the next episode of startup will
come out and a little update I have a
patreon page now you don't need to be a
patron name thing but I'm just gonna
post all the behind the scenes all the
fun stuff that I didn't get to put in
the actual episode I'll put it in there
so you guys can check it out and also
follow me on instagram at ramappa and
twitter at demova
you know so i could talk me together
also thank you guys so much I've now
reached a thousand subscribers and as a
thank you I am going to do a giveaway
more details on that later see ya
[Music]